gerard sending this to us from chicago
police department
the new foot pursuit policy scheduled to
become effective june 11th is designed
to keep both
officers and members of the public safe
and balances the risk of engaging in a
pursuit
with the need to apprehend the
individual details in the press release
cpd foot pursuit policy cpd
chicago police department for the first
time in chicago there's a formal policy
that includes the following provisions
department members are required
to balance the risk of engaging and
pursue with the need to apprehend the
subject officers and supervisors
will not be disciplined for deciding not
to engage or
continue a foot pursuit or for
instructing
that a foot pursuit be discontinued
based on a reasonable assessment of an
incident let me read that one more time
to you
officers cops and supervisors will not
be disciplined
hence punished hence fired hence
written up for deciding not to engage
or continue a foot pursuit meaning if
there's a crime they will not be
punished if they don't continue and
pursue
the individual for instructing that a
foot purse would be discontinued based
on a reasonable assessment of an
incident
there will be specific prohibitions to
uh uh foot pursuit cbt will not pursue
for an offense is less than a classic
misdemeanor
traffic offenses do not disregard
endanger the safety of others
if the immediate need to apprehend the
subject is not worth the risk to
responding officers
the public or the subject officers will
not
intentionally provoke flight to justify
pursuit
mandates the after action review by cpd
chicago police department of foot
pursuits how do you read this when you
read this
what does this mean to you what does it
mean to me yes
it means chicago is playing by gta rules
it's gta 6 chicago
you punch somebody and you run and they
can't chase you what cop in the world
would chase you so let me get this
straight
if i don't chase the guy i face no
discipline
but if i do chase the guy i have a
mandatory after action review
that's what we call disincentive so
what's a class a misdemeanor aggravated
assault battery domestic battery
criminal battery
okay cool so this guy could steal your
car in front of you and you could be
like uh officer he's stealing my car
and officer's like yeah but he's driving
away sorry
sorry hey uh this guy's robbing my store
you think uh
you think you can do something has he
started running yet yeah oh
all right well we'll i'll write a report
this is insanity
it's insanity this is crazy how long
before this gets changed because you
know a lot of these states they come up
with us defund the police and the next
thing you know six
the other day this guy's talking about
defunding the police okay while he's
doing i don't know if you saw this or
not
while he's doing an interview he's a uh
what do you call it one of these
responders correspondence he's in the
streets he's doing an interview
well you know the whole idea about the
city trying to be more responsible
defunding the police
in the background you hear tata
and you hear the guy saying hey call the
cops call the guy what are you talking
about it's
caught on nationals that was uh
minneapolis that was at the jordan
i know exactly that that was the george
floyd hey this year it's like this like
this is
so how long do you think this is even
going to last i'd love to ask you guys i
would like to take
the last i would love nothing more than
to ask mayor laurie lightfoot but uh not
being a person of color i'm not allowed
to
she's only taking interviews from people
of color so maybe you can get her on the
podcast pat and ask her like
hey so um you think it's a good thing to
apprehend criminals or not
if you were to play vegas and if you
were to gamble what are the chances of
the marijuana to come and be a guest on
vacation about the same chances of her
waking up one day and not looking like
sid the sloth
got it so that's it that's uh that's uh
he's creating content for
you know when he does a stand-up but if
you're listening to this and you're
watching a podcast if you're from
chicago
and you didn't know about this and you
just read this what is your reaction to
this
if you're from chicago you're hearing
this adam what are your thoughts on this
so who would implement a law like this
is this actually this is the fourth
largest city in america i'm saying that
is it the chicago police department that
sits down and says look we got to make
some changes oh you're saying who came
up with the yeah who come up
i assume they had a voice in this of
course i assumed they had to sit down
and said guys what
can we do better is it i don't know if
this is this isn't the mayor saying you
guys should do this
this is chicago police department this
is coming from the top down i don't know
this
this just screams de-escalate the police
something i haven't talked about it for
a
while
defund the police is a horrible slogan
it so you actually afford this
i'm not for this but i am in favor of
de-escalating
how do you do dangerous interactions
so what what is that example of a class
a misdemeanor includes aggravated
assault battery domestic
i think i think ultimately what i'm
reading from this if there's some
[ __ ] crime going on i don't know
you know how the car is getting it's a
pickpocket
it's a it's a car your car's going
stolen yeah it's [ __ ]
i do agree i do agree with some bigger
things in life so let the guy steal your
car
yeah i'm not saying why they'll get the
helicopter they'll come over they'll fly
over they'll they'll find the guy
somebody's taking a bat to a school bus
wow buddy it's fine this is coming from
a guy
don't want to bother them on my bike
we've got an issue now
you stole my bike we now have an issue
i'm chasing you if somebody steals your
bike you want the cops to chase somebody
but that's a great point though that's
what's gonna happen especially in
chicago yeah
they're gonna look at the cop and
they're gonna be like you're gonna do
something be like i don't know buddy and
it's gonna be vigilante [ __ ] i don't
know
i don't know exactly what's going on
chicago what i do know is that it's
constantly referred to as
chiraq and some [ __ ] needs to be changed
there
so whatever they've been doing a lot of
friendships whatever they've been doing
bro it needs to be changed there's
something i have one friend in chicago
his name is matt zappala i think you
just put him on the streets he'll clean
that thing up in an instant there is a
very popular show
that tracks detroit and chicago
criminals called first 48.
and the whole premise of the show is
that if you don't catch somebody within
the first 48 hours
you don't catch them it's in miami too
they gone boy yeah so now
not only do you not catch him in the
first 48 you gotta give him a head start
but that show is solving murders not
someone who pickpocketed you okay
bro what about the first 48 they're not
like today we had a pickpocket incident
on the down streets of chicago we've got
all the detectives on the scene
this is they're going to find out people
who stole this guy's wallet dude this is
just
about this is just like who committed
the murder
people on twitter when that guy in dc
died when those two girls were trying to
steal his car they were like why didn't
he just let him take the car
he died it was his fault i was like what
you blaming the victim for his own death
by the way by the way you know you know
what's the problem with this with me
okay what is the basic foundation of
capitalism
what is the basic foundation of free
enterprise it's what is the p
word what's the personal property
property
property okay and property back in the
days
when people who of powerful people tax
you know
government would show up and say this is
officially mine you no longer have this
place it's mine they bullied you off the
streets and you're left and nobody could
say anything about it right
you mean to tell me that car is
someone's property somebody comes and
takes it and cops are not going to
protect the person that owns that
property
that car is someone's property it's
someone owns that someone's paying the
bill for that
the moment i lose the safety
net of making sure somebody can't just
come and take my property what the hell
am i thinking about
look years ago i uh bought a book
and i went in this whole uh books i was
buying about how to start a country
okay and uh one of the books was for you
know adults another one was for kids i
had my kids read this book how to build
your own
country how to start your own country
and you know what the most basic
foundation of a country was you know
what's the first thing
when families back in the days were
thinking about going to another country
to raise their kids and family you know
what's the first thing they thought
about was what the s-word what's the
s-word security security
it's the first thing they're thinking
about is security when you don't have
kids you don't think security
when you have kids you think security
one night
jennifer and i are living in this place
in northridge off of encino boulevard
she would remember this
one day i parked my range rover outside
with navigated community
i go to sleep never owned the gun before
i mean i was in the military i had m16
about saws had all this other stuff that
was in my
go to sleep wake up in the morning i'm
going to work windows shattered they
took my backpack they took my stereo
system and they took
you know what first thing i did is i
went to a gun store i bought a glock i
bought a shotgun
came back i told the guys we're not
living here anymore i went to a local
gated community
near a safe place and i'm moving to that
place simply because of
security i travel a lot i don't want my
family to be
unsafe when i'm on the road doing other
things at the time right okay
this doesn't scream security this a
mother of four is sitting there saying
what if they take my car and my daughter
is in there my kids are in there and
somebody said what if my son
there's no security there there's an
element of this where the government's
not doing their job to protect the
family
if there is certain things we pay taxes
for if there are certain things we pay
taxes for right
one of the things we pay taxes for is to
offer me what security
this is a scary thought what they're
doing and what's funny about this is i
don't think this is going to last a long
time i give this six to 12 months
and i think the people in chicago are
going to flip out and they're going to
notice either an exit is taking place or
they're going to get rowdy and once
people get rowdy people going to change
their positions this is not something
that's going to work no one's going to
go model after this
but if you model after this it's another
you think you're here in exodus in new
jersey or new york or california
you're about to hear a different exodus
from city you don't by the way you don't
hear during the pandemic
one city didn't get a lot of shot taking
out them in chicago chicago was kind of
under the radar chicago gets the shot at
what
number one in homicide number one is
shooting number one and all the stuff
that they've been leading for how long
now yeah forever
forever right but shirak but i think
this
um could really piss off the wrong this
is 24 hours ago
okay this this is put on your other hat
why are they doing this i'll tell you
why that's where i was going with this
this
screams from from a guy who who was in
uh um an administration this screams
political [ __ ] this screams to me
setting the groundwork for her in a year
from now
being able to grandstand on lower crime
rates there's
i reduced crime and blah blah blah look
look at the crime
crime was x and now it's 20 lower it's
not 20
lower you're catching 20 less people
people are stopping they're not calling
the cops on things
you're disincentivities all you're doing
is you're disincentivizing
people to work within the system i'll
tell you something else too
i call this i call this over their
progressives that's who i call this
these are over there progressives
they're very very progressive over there
like oh yeah
you know people are impoverished you
hear it in new york all the time now
people are impoverished if they
if sex work is real work if if she wants
to be a prostitute let her be a
prostitute and
yeah yeah as long as it's over there but
if prostitutes start walking down your
block all of a sudden you're going to be
like well i probably don't need
prostitution in my town oh
you know there's something for new york
that's that's something for the
progressives
let them have all the drugs they want
and the prostitution over there i'm very
progressive
but then they go to their home which is
all white
and gated you know what i'm saying like
this is this goes back to what i was
talking about with you the other day
where people
you know all these you know especially
these rich white liberals bother me man
because they sit here and they're they
they treat other people like their pets
like they're like they're plants that
need to be watered like if it wasn't for
us
how could these people possibly survive
and then they're the ones who put their
windows up
when somebody else comes by they're over
there progressives they're the worst
human beings on earth man and this type
of stuff where they're like oh no
let them you know let them get away with
it but then let that happen to them
and see the [ __ ] that they would do let
them have let this come to their block
in the suburb
20 miles outside the city and let them
watch how quickly they'd be at the town
meeting
you were going to say something are you
you sounded like you're going to say
something you don't think
prostitutes are in nice neighborhoods
too they just do it a different way
they're not they're not they're playing
a [ __ ] on the block yeah which
they're they're dressing up a little
nicer and they're shorter classes here
i'm sure you could have you don't think
i'm sure you can do a tutorial on it
you don't think in boca that there's
some high classier
ladies of the night that are just kind
of doing their thing how does one come
to acquire this knowledge adam
i mean you when you moved here from
jersey i'm sure you've been here two
weeks i'm sure you've been approached
you dress nice you're dressing you're
you roll up in your nice yeah yeah
yeah i see i i i i look like i'm in the
market you show up in a
in a anybody here anybody here from
chicago former pd anybody that's on with
us is chicago former pd i just got a
bunch of comments
josh i know he's from chicago but i'm
looking at seeing if somebody is a
uh i saw josh's comment joshua cops
can't do anything
no former pd oh they've had a terrible
time during the past uh
sad stories liberal governor governors
and still trending
uh marvin just gave a hundred bucks
holly says pat cp
cpd chicago police department national
guard
at times are all over the streets of
chicago especially on the south side
yeah
but they are very selective on who they
charge not every major crime
makes the news it's very easy to buy off
the adrenaline
the adrena adrenal
for protection it's um it's yeah they're
out there looking for maga hats and
nooses and subway sandwiches you know
they got to keep that
they got to keep some streets they got
to keep the streets shout out to juicy
juicy
that's a that's a that's a different
story right there on on what's going on
there yeah you know i
you asked the question he said flip it
what were you going to say flip it as
what
flip it out why would they do something
like this yeah because it's the level of
sensitivity like they're so worried
about walking on egg shells offending
the wrong person
so they're doing something like this so
they don't get the harassment charges
and the
you know people online talking about
what's going on like right now
here's one thing i can't stand that's
happening in the nba oh my gosh
it's driving me nuts so kyrie irving
goes to boston
and he said well the people here are
just i can't say it's just the people
here you know it's just it's just
everybody's a professional victim right
now and then russell westbrook yesterday
gets pissed off and throws uh
popcorn's adam okay i get it fan threw
popcorn at him i would i would lose my
mind if that were to happen i'm an
athlete like he lost
i showed the video yes of course what
the hell are you doing throwing popcorns
at the guy
there ought to be a reaction to it 100
opportunity automatically
lebron jumps in you know race-baiting
hey protecting this
it's the cities you're playing it it's
the cities it's philadelphia it's boston
it's this
knock it off man you're just dividing
this thing more and more you're adding
fuel to the fire even more than what we
already have right now so it happened in
philly philly
threw batteries at santa claus they're
getting mad about freaking popcorn
really
fans they gave a standing ovation to
michael irvin when he broke his death
by the way they're the most
disrespectful people the city billboard
went on where he trashed them
philadelphia yeah there you go so so the
point is listen if you
you can handle it handle it you can't
handle it don't handle it about
this goes back to what i was talking to
you last night man i am so freaking
sick and tired of the repentant rich
i like i'm so if i gotta hear
that freaking that that that that ginger
nerd from the from across the pond
cry one more freaking time about how
hard his freaking life is
uh prince harry and prince uh the
princess uh there
uh if you're a billionaire
literal prince and princess and you
can't be happy
the rest of us should just kill
ourselves like seriously like what what
like why are we doing this if that if
they can't be happy what the hell are
the rest of us even doing
shut up and buy a jet ski like shut up
like do
something like go get like oh my god oh
my god are you gonna take your meghan
markle poster down or you're gonna keep
it up she's a babe don't get me wrong
but i mean just
shut up if i gotta hear lebron james
complained one more time
lebron james sent out a tweet he just
don't get it bro he surrounds himself
with bad people man
he's got too much do you think he's
changing he's got too much minister
in his life bro hell yeah dude the great
minister is as
deep inside of of lebron man and this is
a dude talking about privilege bro
you were born six foot eight
250 pounds you might be the single most
athletic human being to
ever walk the face of the earth some
would say
you were born with privileges some would
say
somebody he might he had a rough goal he
had he did he had a rough
goal of it growing up for like 11 years
before he became a millionaire
like the dude was an aau millionaire at
14 years old
he's been a a millionaire for longer
than he wasn't
this guy is the very embodiment of and
and the thing that bothers me probably
more than anything else about the
repentant rich
is they act like they somehow were good
enough to beat the system
but nobody else is nobody like like aoc
when she goes on her
her tirades about how the system was set
up so that people would
you're 30 you're 30 and you're a member
of congress
you are the very proof of what this
country offers
you are the walking example of the
beauty
of our system shut your freaking
mouth you morons they're so invested
in in in the profitability of victimhood
that if i got leo you know i love his
movies but
like you said they get on the oscars and
here you are you're the most beautiful
people on earth making the most money
you can imagine
doing a job that we all want to do right
think about how easy it is to be an
actor you don't have to write your own
words somebody else writes their words
and then they have to memorize the words
somebody else wrote and they're not even
good at it so they have to have a
director to tell them
how to do it 20 times and then they get
a reward for it it's like a puppy
sit sit oh you sat down yeah here's a
cookie
that's what actors are you know what i'm
saying and we got to sit here and we got
to live
well you know uh we're destroying the
world we
what's this wee [ __ ] i took the
train this morning leo you took a
private jet you
say you you know i'm sorry i'm going on
again but
keep going there's a there's a lot of
truth behind by the way you know there
was an interview with denzel
and the guy's talking about you know uh
how hard life is as an actor says
our job is not hard we are the luckiest
people alive we don't have a hard job so
let me tell you when i started working
i was a trash guy that's what denzel
used to do he was a trash from the
bridge what he did yeah
he used to go pick up trash is what he
did and the guy's like larry king's like
you're kidding me says no that's what i
did he says you know my first job was
and then they were talking about who
they were and what they did at one point
he says
what i do for a living making movies
this is a joke this is not work when i
hear other actors complain about the
fact that we have such a hard job
we don't have a hard job we don't have
something challenging that we're facing
cure
and this is coming from who denzel maybe
one of the most liked actors out there
by
on both sides and he kind of keeps it to
himself because he knows if he says
anything politically
one time a guy asked him a question he
said so who did you vote for have you
seen his response to that when they said
so
denzel did you vote i did who did you
vote for
and he pauses for two seconds none of
your damn business really he said none
of your damn
business denzel said and you see people
saying oh okay i'm just wondering people
want to know no people don't want to
know it's none of your damn business who
i voted for
but i voted for somebody they don't want
to want to judge you of course because i
mean
if a hollywood actor tells you none of
your damn business who do they vote for
you just have to know what that means i
don't know you understand you told the
world who you voted for
you voted for whoever your party your
community wouldn't be happy about hence
you don't see you know some of these
guys like denzel getting as much of the
spotlight so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye